asumiendo que tenemos un 9.0 87
15.31 como lo sumarían los invito a que
paren el vídeo por un momento y lo
intenten ustedes solos
listo considerando que ustedes han
buscado hacer esta suma y tal vez
se acomodaron aquí 7 1883 11 y llevamos
1 estaríamos cometiendo un error esta
forma de colocar los números con
decimales es incorrecta por lo que antes
debemos de colocarlos de la manera
adecuada cómo va a ser esto dependiendo
del punto recuerden que del punto hacia
la izquierda nos maneja los enteros y
del punto hacia la derecha todos los
decimales así es que lo que va a notar
esta diferencia será el punto vamos a
reescribir lo les parece vamos a hacer
espacio
ahora tenemos que 9 puntos 0 87 se
sumará a 15 unidades por eso ponemos
primero el punto 15 unidades más 31 que
de hecho aquí si queremos podemos
ponerle un 0 ya que del punto hacia la
derecha podemos agregar los para que se
vea completo este bloque vamos a hacer
la suma ahora sí cuántos eran 70 es
igual a 78 más uno es igual a 9
es más 0 es igual a 3 colocaremos el
punto en blanco siempre para que ustedes
vean dónde se encuentra se ven como
todos están alineados y ahora nos vamos
con las unidades 9 + 5 es igual a 14 que
14 es igual a 4 unidades más una decenas
se acuerdan ahora tenemos que una decena
más una decena es igual a dos decenas
o 2020 424 así es que 9.187 15.31 es
igual a 24.39 vamos bien